おはようございます。
今日のプリティーシリーズニュースをお届けします。
まずはアイドルランドプリパラからです。
6月10日は、ファララとガァララの誕生日。
公式アカウントでは、日付が変わった6月10日0時から、フォトスタジオにバースデー背景が追加されたことが案内されました。
ファララ、ガァララと一緒に記念撮影ができる、誕生日らしい特別なコンテンツです。
さらに、バースデーユメガチャの開催など、ふたりをお祝いする配信内容も告知されています。
SNSでもファララ生誕祭2026ガァララ生誕祭2026のハッシュタグで、お祝いイラストやスクリーンショットの投稿が広がっています。
また、6月10日のメンテナンス後からは、新たな公式プロミスとして不思議の国のノンシュガー 撮影会が配信されています。
あわせて不思議の国のノンシュガー ユメガチャの開催も案内されており、ノンシュガーらしいワンダーランド感のあるコーデや撮影テーマに注目です。
続いておねがいアイプリです。
6月10日朝に放送されたおはスタでは、おねがいアイプリでレッツダンス、そしてバトルTHE論パワー特別編が紹介されました。
朝の番組内でアイプリに触れられたことで、アニメやゲームをまだ知らない子どもたちにも届く、うれしい露出となっています。
続いてキングオブプリズムです。
6月10日発売のアニメディア7月号に、舞台キングオブプリズム -Your Endless Call- みんなきらめけ！
キンプリ☆ツアーズの記事が掲載されています。
コーナープリズムスタァを愛するフレンドの会では、古谷大和さんと小林竜之さんの名前が紹介されており、舞台版キンプリに注目した内容になっています。
さらに、AMOCAFE WEB SHOPでは、6月10日18時からキングオブプリズム 10th ANNIVERSARY展 〜Road to the Dramatic Future〜関連商品の通販受付が始まっています。
受付期間は7月10日23時59分までと案内されており、展示会に足を運べなかった方や、買い逃したグッズがある方にとっても注目の通販スタートです。
今日のプリティーシリーズは、ファララとガァララの誕生日を祝うアイドルランドプリパラの更新、朝番組でのおねがいアイプリ紹介、そしてキングオブプリズムの雑誌掲載と10周年展グッズ通販が大きな話題となりました。
それでは、今日も素敵なプリティーシリーズライフをお過ごしください。
以上、今日のアイプリニュースでした。